our guests this afternoon is Professor
Tom Pettit who will present on the
Gutenberg parenthesis discerning
historical patterns in media technology
cultural production and perception
professor Pettit is an associate
professor at the University of Southern
Denmark Institute of literature media
and cultural studies where he lectures
on literature and theatre in the late
medieval and early modern periods his
research is devoted to exploring a
performance culture located in the
triangle of literature theater and
folklore
he has published many studies on customs
folk drama and pageantry legends and
wonder tales he has also worked
extensively on medieval drama and
Elizabethan theater including
folkloristic approaches to shakespeare
and Marlowe his subject this afternoon
is a so-called Gutenberg parenthesis and
the question of whether our emerging
digital culture is partly a return to
certain practices and ways of thinking
that were central to human societies
before the advent of the printing press
and its many collateral media of
cultural production our distinguished
respondent commentator is Professor
Peter s Donaldson Pete is professor of
literature at MIT and author of two
books Machiavelli in the mystery of
state and Shakespearean films
Shakespearean directors as well as
numerous publications on Shakespeare and
film and digital media he directs the
MIT Shakespeare electronic archive which
since 1992 has used computers to develop
new ways of studying Shakespeare across
the media of text image and film related
digital products include Hamlet on the
ramparts x-mas a cross media annotation
system and Shakespeare performance in
Asia the first phase of a global
Shakespeare video archive Tom will
present his argument for the first
half-hour Pete will then respond and
we'll open the forum to discussion thank
you
thank you very much professor Paradis
and my thanks too to you and to david
Thorburn for letting me come into this
this forum and to Peter Donaldson for
joining the conversation bread - bread
for practical work thank you all for
joining us on this unseasonally warm
afternoon it will be a conversation I'm
trying to get used to the the microphone
and and I've got wires in places I don't
often have lines it's very appropriate
I'm kind of in a cyborg condition which
is which is which we may be discussing
later on
I've Harris the organizers into allowing
me to give a perhaps more substantial
opening to the earth to the session then
may normally be the case with your with
your forums it's for two reason two
reasons it's mainly they know I'm better
at presenting ideas that are discussing
ideas if you present me with a good
question I will have the answer but
it'll be as my plane comes in to
Copenhagen Airport early on Sunday
morning it'll be too late for you I can
email you my answer question but let's
see how it goes and also I'd like this
opportunity to establish as a basis for
the conversation exactly what I
understand by the the Gutenberg
parenthesis it is other and more than
the phase of media history between oral
tradition and digital technology which
is suggested by the other title and I
hope you're all insight of the year
you're all is either hand out and the
handout reproduces some of the most
essential of the small cluster of
PowerPoint slides very simple elementary
PowerPoint slides that I have prepared
for today's presentation
now the Gutenberg parenthesis has proved
an elegant an effective and therefore a
quite provocative way of formulating a
thesis about the long term history of
media history it has provoked a good
deal of positive response and a good
deal of negative response since I've
been presenting the idea here at here in
here in in Boston in
which it's about the deep history of
media far beyond to today's new media
the internet and digital technology
beyond even the old media which is what
new media people call film and
television to my it to my disappointment
we we have a Media Studies fairly new
Media Studies department in in
University of Southern Denmark and I was
delighted to see that they were doing
old media because I could say something
about ballads and folk tales and legends
from the Middle Ages and lo and behold
old media was film and television I'm
very pleased that attitudes to the
history of media are otherwise over here
so we're talking about effectively the
the prehistory from from that
perspective the prehistory of the media
in the form of printing and writing and
and then the human voice as the means of
communication this idea about the
printers is it suggests that knowledge
of what happened in that relatively
distant past can be more than usually
helpful in understanding what's
happening in the present and what may
happen in the future and vice versa and
for me of course it's the vice versa
that's important
I do not present myself as an expert on
the modern media I'm particularly
interested in the in the modern media
but if studying the modern media will
help me better understand my own field
made it even relational studies which is
what this parenthetical notion suggests
I'm very happy to exchange information
and insights with people who are experts
in modern media which is why I keep
coming back to MIT the parentheses image
also explains why as a student of
Shakespeare
I've always felt more comfortable when
I'm not studying Shakespeare in working
on folklore and in working on
african-american culture in working on
the modern media more so than when
teaching regular canonical literature of
the period in between of the
parenthetical period off of Milton and
Pope and Swift and words with an Sakurai
and Kipling all those great masterpieces
of the of
Western Canon though those that I'll say
in passing I will downplay Shakespeare
in my initial presentation because I
know jolly well we're gonna have a jolly
good conversation about about
Shakespeare in a moment these are some
of the places we may be going in the
course of this forum but I'd like to
start with the help of my powerpoints by
exploring the potential value of the
Gutenberg parenthesis idea in suggesting
answers to some important questions
about the new media and their impact
which are currently the matter of urgent
discussion and as my first PowerPoint
shows in a very influential article in
the Atlantic magazine in in 2008
Nicholas Carr strikingly formulated what
many people have been asking themselves
is Google making us stupid and he has a
book coming out on the same subject
in a few in a month or so and a couple
of months ago the American edge
foundation which poses an annual
question to its star studded panel of
academics and artists unveiled it's
question for 2010 and which has
subsequently been discussed and reported
in most of the world series newspapers
how is the internet changing the way you
think translate into my powerpoint
presentation in my own simplified terms
how is change in media technology
affecting our what I call our mind work
which is my plane man's term for
cognition I will say cognition in due
course but I say mind work to start just
to emphasize I simply mean what happens
in the mind the work that the mind the
work that the mind does of course both
these questions beg questions the first
one assumes that before Google we
weren't stupid and as someone who was
there at the time you have my personal
assurance we were what the question
really means is is Google making a
stupid in a different way which is
effectively a rephrasing of the of the
second question how is the internet
changing the way you think and the
Gutenberg parenthesis answer to both is
is yes it is changing the way we think
and quite specific the Internet will
ultimately make us think
the way medieval peasants thought or
it's making us stupid you know or Google
is making a stupid in a more medieval
rustic sort of a way which may be an
improvement on present conditions except
of course both questions are problematic
in assuming the influence and it goes
the one way they are guilty of
technological determinism the cardinal
sin of media studies influence can
equally go the other way
mind work can influence or determine the
development of media technology so we
could ask with equal legitimacy is our
stupidity making Google how is the way
you think changing the internet or even
was it a change in the way we think that
created the internet rephrasing
rephrasing their questions and then
thirdly finally each of each of these
questions arm it's a vital third
ingredient media technology may
influence mind work mind work my
influence media technology but either
way the influence is likely to pass
through or show itself in the cultural
production which is produced by that
mind work and mediated by that
technology I mean the plays the Opera
the musicals the films the legends the
tales the pulp fiction the novels poems
songs jokes ermine cereals and soaps
rumors and news reports gossip chat and
twittering everything that is mediated
by the media and for some of us those
who think that the with Hamlet that the
plays the thing those of you who are
studying media in the sense of what the
media mediate our topic our topic is the
cultural production the plays themselves
the stories themselves the books
themselves the novels themselves and the
mind work and the mediated and the
technology are contexts for that
production I therefore rephrase them as
contexts for cultural production in my
in that current the current PowerPoint
context we need to know more about in
order to better to appreciate the
content and the form and the meaning of
that culture
so my formulation of the edge question
would be how is the internet changing
the way you create changing the way you
write how is it changing the way you
produce words and the Gutenberg
parenthesis answer would be it's making
me create a bit more like Shakespeare
which brings us back to the historical
dimension we are evidently in the middle
of a revolution in communications which
is manifestly impacting on culture
production and prompting these questions
about its impact on cognition started in
the 20th century with recording with
sounds and film with sound and film
recording multiplied by radio and
television and now supplemented and
enhanced by the internet and digital
technology and there's a common theme in
commentary that these developments
constitute not just something new but
the end of something old that they are a
challenge to the dominance of print and
the book and reading and I just that
there are there are there are now
publications with titles like the end of
books the gutenberg eligible reading and
electronic age the end of the reign of
the book there's a collection if that is
called beyond the book and one of the
articles in it is called we are already
beyond the book the book is dead with an
extra subtitle long live the book a a
heretical voice in this chorus and
famously Jeff Jeff Gomez is the print is
dead books in our digital age and of
course talking about the end of the book
I'll wait until it goes away even if
it's uh me say I'm busy alright thank
you much talking about the end of the
book invites us of course to juxtapose
that with the beginning of the book with
the emergence of printing and and and
the printed book and another one of the
influential works on this field in this
field is Peter Schilling Berg started
from 2006 which is entitled from
Gutenberg to Google where his thesis is
we are in the infancy we are now in the
infancy of a textual revolution
comparable to the one initiated by the
invention of printing from movable type
in the 15th century to revolutions
Gutenberg revolution Google Revolution
three phases the two revelation
the two revolutions taking us from one
level of technology to another in in in
mediating context from a low technology
of personal face-to-face oral mediation
with some writing a step upwards in
technology with Gutenberg into an
intermediate technology with textual
mediation by the printed book and then
the Google revolution to a higher
technology with the electronic media
digital technology the internet and CMC
computer mediated communication which
suggests of course and juxtaposing Lee
in it so in itself that suggests chapter
posing these two revolutions should be
mutually enlightening we can studying
the Gutenberg Revolution with hope can
help us better understand the Google
revolution in a 1995 position paper for
the RAND Corporation James Dewar title
was entitled the war was called the
Information Age and the printing press
looking backward to see ahead the book
historian Roger Chartier
sees that can see that one revolution
can help us to understand the other and
conversely from the present from the
present to the past we can use I can use
the Google revolution to better
understand the Gutenberg Revolution and
what it meant to Shakespeare and others
and people work in my
field arthur marathi and michael bristol
have edited a collection of studies on
print manuscript and performance the
changing relations of the media in early
modern England they say they will study
the complex interactions back then in
Shakespeare's time between a
technologically advanced culture of the
printed book and a still powerful
traditional culture based on the spoken
world word spectacle and manuscript
looking back from our own era looking
back from now from the Google aged look
to the Gutenberg Revolution looking back
from our own transitional moment as we
attempt to negotiate the shift from
typographic to electronic and visual
media and there are others there are
universities who have sought grants on
the basis of juxtaposing this modern
revolution with the 16th century
revolution with the Renaissance
Revolution with an aim to to the
reciprocal enlightenment on on both
sides and of course Marshall McLuhan
famously has referred to the Gutenberg
galaxy as the name for that for the for
the phrase in between and that those two
revolutions can be compared in their
impact on the nature of human thinking
and many other things there others have
done the same Walter Ong also famously
has developed this notion of secondary
Orianna or secondary secondary orality
that we are moving we are moving into
something that resembles even more the
past we are going through a period of
print moving into a secondary orality
which takes us in many ways back to the
primary orality of the preprint period
and that's moving on to something else
because this is the notion that not we
are not merely moving up in technology
on into a third phase but that third
phase of media history is taking us back
in many ways to the period between
another renaissance scholar lia Marcus
in a striking study called cyberspace
renascence
has noted that in in modern electronic
editions texts are becoming more fluid
less stable more subject to intervention
by people who copy them and that
therefore they are that that situation
is taking us back to how things were in
the age of manuscripts in the age when
the age of the shakespeare period where
texts were not as stable as they became
in the meantime I some of you may recall
from the conference here last year the
program borrowed a very effective
cartoon from the Denver Post suggesting
that we are moving back the future is
taking us back into the past the
suggestion that the suggestion that the
mailing and tweeting that's the right
term are a reversion to the limited the
limited communicative capacities of off
stone tablets so we are the future is
taking us back to the past and the most
important figure in this field perhaps
is John Foley from the Center for oral
tradition at the University of Missouri
who has instigated this massive project
pathways of the mind with a splendid
website which explores the similarities
between preliterate morality the the
world of oral traditions and the post
the post Guttenberg phenomenon of
digital texts which are which are
accessible on the Internet
John Foley has said has talked about the
fundamental similarities between
humankind's oldest and most pervasive
communications medium oral tradition on
the one hand and humankind's newest
medium the internet that the two are
reasonably juxtaposed and then finally
my colleague Lars oldest our burger at
the University of Southern Denmark
payment came up with this delightful
phrase the the Guttenberg parentheses
suggesting that as in a sentence
we have been through our sentence the
sentence which is the history of the
media has been interrupted
by the age of print by a printing a book
phase and that insofar as we are leaving
that book phrase we are going back we
are going back to the situation before
that without any implications that the
period in between was a waste of time or
going in the wrong direction or
misguided it's not parentheses in a
pejorative sense it's like in a sentence
if you're speaking of sentence or
writing a sentence you interrupt for a
while with a second thought to add to
your first thought you then resume the
first thought at the end of the
parenthesis and the sentence goes on but
that sentence will be irrevocably
changed by what has happened well at
least I think so in the in the
parenthesis in between it is not it has
not been a digression or something not
worthwhile it's also very appropriate of
course in the sense that the parenthesis
as an idea and the parentheses the
brackets as as symbols were themselves
the products of the age of print and
were introduced and appreciated in the
in the in the in the sixteenth century I
have all kinds of qualifications to this
to this picture in the sense that it
doesn't all happen in 1600 it is very
gradual it comprises many different
aspects some things happen at one time
and some things happen at another and
when I say 1600 and 2000 I'm referring
if you like to mainstream to the
mainstream culture of Western Europe and
subsequently of North America other
there'll be other timetables for
subcultures within cultures and there'll
be different timetables for different
cultures which is why folklore when I
study folklore I'm effectively studying
the culture of people who have not yet
entered the Gutenberg parenthesis even
though the main the mainstream the the
majority culture around them has entered
the Guttenberg Prince's is also why we
may come back to this african-american
vernacular culture is so interesting or
can't be seen in a new light from this
perspective that in America there have
been different subcultures they have
entered this parentis
at different times and there's been
interesting discrepancies between them
as a con as a consequence in the little
time I've got left I'd like to that is
the basic situation I'd like to take a
bit of a look at exactly what it is that
characterizes the the parentheses in in
the time that I have our focus on what's
happening in the parentheses but the
implication is that before the
parentheses and after the parentheses
things were different and they were
different in the in the same way and as
far as I can I'll be I'll try and be
consistent and sort of move slowly up
the diagram in those various levels this
is this is the overall situation just
focus on leaf and icons on the central
part it's extraordinary simple but I
seem to find patterns it seems that
there there have been changes around
about 1600 around about 2000 there have
been changes under all three headings
under the heading of the mediating
context and culture production and the
cognitive context and they seem to be
the same changes and the second change
seems to reverse the first change so as
I say this is this isn't nothing
pretentiously intellectual it's it boils
down to some very some very basic things
so with regard for example to the
mediating context the key word is
containment words have been imprisoned
in the Gutenberg parenthesis if one if
one thinks of all the the ways words
have been regimented thanks to this
technology
words are regimented into lines of the
same length on the same height those
lines are structured into a block of
text that that block of text is
surrounded by a margin within a page
those pages are folded and gathered then
they are stitched together then several
gatherings are put together in a book
and glued together
and that book is bound and then put in
covers it may then be put into a
dust-jacket and it may be put into a
slip case or in some cases it may be
provided with metal clasps to stop the
words from getting out it seems
extraordinary level an extraordinary
level of containment and there's not
time but we do the same thing with
letters when you write a letter to
someone you write it on the paper you
fold the paper you put the paper engine
envelope but therefore becomes an
enclosure and you seal the envelope
command and send it off we are we are we
are imprisoning words we're putting
words into things and with regard to
printing how do they get there the words
get into those containers by something
we call the press and there's a very
good reason why it's called a press it
was Gutenberg Gutenberg's didn't make
many changes to existing machinery the
press was previously that same device
was previously used for pressing Jews
out of our lives and grapes and into
barrels into bottles was just a question
of slightly adapting the technology so
whereas previously that press was used
for for getting juice out of out of
vegetables out of out of olives and
grapes into Bettinger barrels so now we
are using or the Gutenberg used the
press to press the words into the pages
into the book into the into the
container into into volumes which have
contents the whole the whole vocabulary
is that of containment and then just to
finish that off when we buy one of those
books full of words even we are if you
like confined within the book because a
lot of those books are designed for
what's called immersive reading we
ourselves we ourselves we immerse
ourselves in that text and we are lost
in the book is the is a conventional
phrase so it's a question the Gutenberg
Prince this is a question of confining
containing words and there's not really
time for this but
one thing that makes this change all the
more striking or make but may make the
connection with Gutenberg less firm is
that similar things seem to be happening
in other forms of production in other
for in other in other in other media all
happens round about the same time words
get confined in books around about the
same time that players get confined to
stages players weren't performed on sort
of stages necessary than that kind of
stage and stages get conferred confined
into theaters and performances occur
sort of in venues music is performed in
concert now in concert halls opera
houses in orchestra pits music is
printed in behind staves in staves
behind bars and and you need the right
key to get them out again there is this
extraordinary influence with the sense
sense of containment that was the media
themselves and it has its impact on what
is produced for those media and and
communicated in those media and I will I
will use this diagram just to summarize
that looks just about right if you like
that was them the media contains but
then the the product itself is contained
it is separate it is cut off from others
this is an indication of what's going on
in this diagram the squares indicate
that this period this same transition
sees the emergence of something we take
for granted and that is the individual
work that the notion that there that a
verbal product has to be a work a story
with a beginning and a middle and an end
the notion that a piece of music has to
have to last a certain amount of time
the notion of a picture is one picture
it is a picture of just one thing and
doesn't crawl all over a wall and
involve all kinds of sequences of action
and that and that works are complete the
notion that a given a given work isn't a
fragment it has a beginning and end it
doesn't just kind of
wander on it doesn't it doesn't just
stop arbitrarily as things might have
been before and Addis things may it may
well be may well be after works become
isolated they are not based on sources
they don't plagiarize earlier works they
are not much imitated they're much
influenced by other works they are
original they belong to the man who
creates them and then when they are
created they are passed on they are
mediated with as little change as
possible before and after the the
parentheses change was a normal
interference was normal works weren't
defended from external interference by
some kind of imaginary imaginary war
so there's summarizing brutally now just
just to get to cover the whole ground
for the first time around the media are
contained the works are contained I
forgot to say I I don't think I knew
that the idea of a framed picture was so
late we take that for granted two
pictures were framed rough at the same
time that words were enclosed in books
and then finally on the last big topic
is I anticipate that there's some
connection say I won't say which way the
connection is there are changes at the
same time in the way we look at the
world the way that people see the world
this is the cognition term that I was
hesitant to use earlier on but the way
people perceive the world the way well
it's gone to my main example bodies and
this is not me I've got to say at the
start a lot of this isn't my own work
I'm in a pre parenthetical or post
parenthetical mode where i reaiiy
redeploy ideas from other people and
this too I came across this they said
these are my own diagrams but this
notion I came across this extraordinary
idea in a frame
buh-buh-buh by a Swiss scholar called
Guilmette Bolin's ello chic decor
article a k-map poland's detects a very
interesting shift in the way we see
bodies and she also links it to the
difference between orality and literacy
the bodies are how we see them we
construct we don't see the word the
world as it is we perceive the world and
we represent and treat the world in
terms of preconceived structures
structures and shapes in our minds those
shapes change and the changes seem to be
correlated to these changes in media
technology and an occult reproduction
and say with regard to the body that the
body the body is how we see it and how
we see it changes and this theory will
say that I've chosen some sort of these
are illustrations rather than
documentation but the basic point is
that within the parenthesis this is
Poland sirs theory within within the
apprentice of my term of course but in
the age of literacy and print the body
is seen as an envelope
we represent the body we perceive the
body we treat the body as an envelope
and the well-being of the body is
dependent on the integrity of that
envelope so that there is no no improper
ingress or egress into the body or from
the body and our culture again this
corresponds in our culture to obsession
the period of the Gutenberg parenthesis
strangely corresponds to the the notions
of etiquette all these things we were
told to do and not to do with our bodies
all that upbringing don't spit don't
burp breathe through your mouth eat with
your door eat with your mouth open don't
gape don't go for cover your mouth when
you cough cover your nose when you
sneeze keep your stomach in keep your
legs and your knees together all that
all that business came in came in with
the book it seems extraordinary
think things change I mean etiquette
changes attitudes change but the idea
that our bodies are envelopes and that
it is the control of that envelope which
is essential for the body even the way
we dress dressing get into the sordid
details but there is an awful
containment of the body by changes in
clothing not least undergarments rough
at the same time I've got to two small
points door to two remaining points I
can do there very quickly the same thing
applies to space there's not a
correlation the way we see space seems
to have changed over the same period and
perhaps in the same way the way we look
at the world with the way of the way we
make maps the way we orient ourselves in
the physical environment I've provided
you again but illustration rather than
proof in the Gutenberg parenthesis the
world is seen in terms of enclosures we
look at Nations at communities at
gardens at estates at houses things that
people own keep us keep other people out
of our enclosure
whereas before and after the world was
seen in terms of movement of avenues and
junctures and just turned out rather
neatly might my illustration is concerns
navigation in the parentheses navigation
is on uses charts printed in books and
navigation takes the form of orienting
oneself in relation to space an enclosed
space one charts one positions on a map
whereas prior to that people navigated
or navigation books navigation aids were
instructions on when to when to go to
support and when you go to starboard
what what landmark to aim for these are
pilot books these are routiers Rutter's
navigation took the form of following
instructions on when to turn left when
to turn right when to head for a given
landmark and say it seems to be
returning in the vision
of the world around us that we have with
GPS and in my fight my final point I'll
just I'll just mention it without going
further into it but it's probably
perhaps too big for today but the final
containment I'm accusing the I'm
accusing the book I'm accusing the
Gutenberg parenthesis of containing
everything of making a seed see
everything in terms of containments and
the last and the biggest is categories
categories the notion that we see the
world in terms of categories that there
are the people can be categorized in
terms of race in terms of gender in
terms of species all those big divides
that wasn't always the case
medieval medicine distinguished three
genders male female and hermaphrodite no
great no great fuss we are approaching
that perception with great difficulty
and pain in our time human medieval
thought didn't distinguish too sharply
between man and animal man and material
man and machine and we are now
approaching a kind of pre pre Gutenberg
medieval notion that borders our
crossable that things overlap and well
that is that is my conclusion for that
part the India's my answer under that
last-hitting
is that the Internet will make us less
categorical in the way we perceive the
world it'll make us less panicky less
worried about distinctions between the
human and the divine the human and the
Machine the human and the animal the
living and the dead the black and the
white the male and the female between
writing and speech it'll make us less
aggressive about transgressions of
categories so in a way when I said when
I say we are going back the internet
will make us think like medieval
peasants
I think that there may be some some
healthy aspects to it I'll stop there
Joe thanks very much
turn it over to Pete thank you
thank you
well it was a little unclear exactly
whether this would be a three-way
discussion or response and how much it
would have to deal with Shakespeare so
sort of winging it a little bit but I
think that first of all I wanted to
thank Tom for his wonderful presentation
I should say even its exaggerations I
thought healthy and helpful and helped
us to get a sense of when and how the
book and the regime of the book and
other such totalizing regimes can weigh
upon creativity I know
Tom's already in advance said there's
another side to this and that books
books are not merely engines for the
compression and restriction and policing
of meaning and indeed there are but I
found this a very very helpful talk and
and I love the the metaphors and the
visualizations that he brought that he
brought to this I thought Tom was going
to speak about Shakespeare and about the
sort of what would you say the arch
fetishized book which is the Shakespeare
folio and maybe he will a little bit
later but maybe are you gonna talk about
that later or what yeah well okay
because what I'm going to start with it
so I mean as an example because this was
the start in some ways it was the symbol
of what a lot of people actually that's
a facsimile or do you think of the
collected works of Shakespeare which
this is not there's a facsimile edition
but the big book with all the plays by
an authoritative editor and commentary
by authoritative scholars and it went
along with their social practice of the
Shakespeare lecture where we don't
actually have Shakespeare lecturers at
MIT we have discussion sections and
other kinds of things like that
any
even Shakespeare students writing
multimedia hyper text essays on
Shakespeare in the in these days but
when I began that was the figure of the
authoritative professor at the front of
the room like me and right now with a
hundred people more or less the official
interpreter of a sacred book which had a
unique and unitary meaning or if it
didn't the aim was to was to come as
close to that as possible which had an
originally an authorized printed form
which if the historical facts did not
actually make it possible to specify
that form at least that's what one was
after as an editor and so but in the
mind of a generation of people who went
through this regime is still common in
many parts of the world like perhaps
very close to here in certain way but
other university but there was an urgent
in the profession that kind of peaked in
the mid 1980s and it had a number in the
shakespeare profession I had a number of
inputs one was was that the the fact of
variation of texts right half of
Shakespeare's plays appear in two
different versions they not always very
different sometimes there there are only
only what you say nominally different no
major differences but but half of the
plays appearing in Cornell which is
small and in folio which is that size
after Shakespeare's death 36 plays
published after Shakespeare's death in
1660 after seven years after 1623 during
Shakespeare's lifetime about half the
plays appear in court oh and sometimes
they are surprising differences for for
example to be or not to be that is the
question one of the most famous lines
appears in the first quarter as to to be
or not to be I there's the point and
it's kind of hard to of variation that's
meaningful because instead of it being
the question it's more or less the point
and the answer and so but and there are
profound differences Hamid as a play for
which there are three significantly
different texts first quarter second
quarter and and folio King Lear has to a
fellow has fascinating differences
between the 1622 quarter and the folio
in hundreds of individual words unlike
King Lear and Hammett is not a matter of
whole scenes or or long passages but
individual words seem to have been
changed and we don't always know which
way since the date of publication is not
necessarily the date of the underlying
document so so in fact the in textual
studies that use it were a dawn mission
because you don't know whether something
was added or omitted if you're if you
don't know the dates of the text or
whether or the probe or this stammer you
don't know how they descended from one
another so that was one thing the text
varied a lot and the knowledge of this
variation was hidden an impossibly tiny
print at the end of the book that nobody
ever used and you would need a little
bit of a course to to understand that
that that was one one one thing the
other was the question of performance
how do we how do we acknowledge
adequately the fact that Shakespeare
came to Stratford as an actor made his
way up as a as a writer yes he took on
the heirs of a gentleman and wrote
sonnets and they were published a
problem with probably with more more
supervision while more in tension than
some of the other intensive Shakespeare
but he was a man of the theater and in
the theatre the variation is is
inescapable because theatrical
productions vary from one day to the
next right from one performance to the
next they can't help but vary that way
and of course they vary even perhaps
more grossly in one production to the
next in one language to the next one
culture taking up the text and an
understanding at a different way so
variations seem to be in many many ways
cultural textual performative something
that needed a
nology and and some of the steps taken
and i think this would would be a very
good example of words of the idea that
words were being constricted in a
certain kind of way and that we could
loosen the bonds of the prevent assists
we didn't use the word at the time and
and and create something with more flow
more inclusion and and more honesty to
the fact of what the human labor of
writing play is like and how subject it
is to variation and to imperfection on
all sorts of levels whether it's the
imperfection of the writer who can come
up with a word like print [ __ ] that no
one has ever heard before our sins and
somehow that gets into the text or or
other performers or the editors and so
it seemed difficult within the within
the margins of the book to give adequate
adequate form to this and so i wanted to
also look at another kind of book very
for a minute which is well very
well-known scholars started trying to
find alternate alternate ways within the
limit of a bound book to give readers
access to the fact that variation didn't
all work out this is a this is by my
friend michael warren you know at santa
cruz and this is the the parallel king
lear
now he thought the way to really
represent the facts of king lear was to
take the first quarto and the folio
version and to put them side-by-side but
since the books are of different sizes
you had he had to develop this method
very complicated technological method
called cut cut line facsimile right so
first you take a picture of the page
then you cut it so the reader can cross
right over from for the comparable parts
of the of the corner and folio right but
there are different sizes so there's
white spaces in between and very very
hard to read a legibility was a great
deal of the problems what Michael did
for the next stage was to publish this
book along with on
fascicles of the three texts so that you
could shift them and and compare them as
we're reading he thought it was rather
awkward so he actually in a sense
renounced the practice of editing at all
within the within the confines of the
Codex or the facsimile and he joined our
early efforts to find a way out of this
out of the confines of the book
it's rejoined our team at MIT in in the
hopes of finding a way of representing
this variation and I wanted to give you
just a few examples of what the kind of
thing we were doing then and why is it
maybe preface it by saying parentheses
there's a curious we even talked about
the Gutenberg parenthesis and I kept
thinking for the first time I didn't
thought it about it till tom was talking
that there's a kind of parentheses
around the period about it that I'm
about to exemplify which is the period
of hypertext hyper media standalone
hypertext hyper media well as a the
novelist Robert couvert declares the end
of books in 1994 in the New York Times
and in 2002 you still can get it online
thanks to Nick keeping it keeping it
alive online the article I think stay at
the end of hypertext or about the fading
of the golden age of hypertext which
lasts some vanishingly small period from
vision in 1984 to 2002 so they're gonna
have the hypertext parenthesis as well
and we may have the Google parenthesis
because it free years we think it is we
may find that it's very confining in the
end who knows we don't know but there'll
always be this tension between something
that confines in its own way and a
larger reality I was I was going to
quote Solomon's prayer at the completion
of the temple is something like but 10
but can this house ever hold the
immensity of the Lord so you know you
have something completed but with the
recognition that there's no way that the
confinement is going to work in that
part of the point
part of the point is that there's a
great deal outside the effort to confine
so there's what we started we started
with three phases for our this
originally standalone project on
workstations and we actually have a
developer and designer ed Moriarty who
some of this work is I think much of it
may be all of it but a great deal we're
grateful to him we did this was kind of
a secret reason it's because the three
phases of shakespeare actually
represents three different states of the
engraved portrait because Shakespeare
was important enough it was important
enough to get this right so that plate
was removed and worked on and put back
twice so and uh most people can't tell
there's a hair strand loose in one
probably two we don't have the
resolution to tell which one it is
and in one his head looks like John the
Baptist on a platter and then the artist
put in some shading so he wouldn't look
quite so cut off from his from his body
intellectually looking fellow a
prosperous gentleman type with a big
brain and a rock star of the medium of
print no one had ever had a full page
portrait of themselves on the
frontispiece they had a full face
portraits Edmund Spenser's works had a
portrait but it took up a tiny part of
the page Shakespeare was a pop star in
the sense that he dominated what the
book was and if you've seen if we could
open that and show you but you couldn't
get beyond the fact of variation even in
this medium so we we based our work on
the idea that it was the variation the
struggling against the attempt to
confine words that needed addressing by
by displaying their variation but also
their variation into media dreamt of a
none dreamt of in Shakespeare's time we
wanted to have the text relate to its
afterlife in art in illustration and in
videos from our own time of course we
ran into lots of copyright problems some
of them
actually solved even now as it would be
no surprise to you so so this is an
example of what you might call the
expanded book way of trying to break out
of that parentheses a mode in some ways
which is superseded even on our own work
but we tried to do it well and so we had
a choice among electronic texts on the
left so there's the principle of
multiplicity and on the right you'll
click and you could get either it's a
little hard reading in the screen
folio which is there a folio facsimile
and you can blow it up and stuff and but
you could also get the earlier corner
editions if they existed of a given play
and juxtapose them with the width of
folio or click on an art field and it
would give you a thumbnail a stream of
thumbnails you could click on those and
you get all right for all all linked to
either that exact line or as we sort of
compromised every two or three lines
right we decide where where the
resources went but notice it was still
tech centric right so we're kind of
radiating out from the Shakespeare text
one way to look at it was that were in
fact creating a more monstrous a kind of
a worship of the author by you know
having being able to move out from one
line to various resources but we thought
of it as liberating I think it is in
some ways it gives you a lot of
information about what different lines
have men now you notice maybe you didn't
know it is it I don't know if that's
visible but I wanted to show you our
chosen and some of you have heard me
talk with noise my favorite example the
first letter the first phoneme well it
isn't really it's it's a yeah it is it's
the first word spoken in Shakespeare
play in the folio because The Tempest
comes first is the word bolson and the
compositor who was working that day a
compositor II who's the bet the worst of
the five managed to put the letter
upside down and be decorated the big
decorated letter
that would be it would be the first
thing that you saw and you turn to an
actual play so so then going back what
this addition allows you to do is look
at any of the four there are four
separate states even within the folio
there are four separate states of the
first page you know and one of them
contains this egregious error well it's
it's it's not a not really called a
significant variation since you know
which way the letter really ought to go
but it also accesses a kind of
materiality of the book because the the
paradox here is the this miserable copy
this must be one of the worst pages of
the folio in existence is all Foxton
damaged and other places water damaged
and it has this this awful typo was
laborious Lea cut out and re pasted into
a full page and bound and the join
between the bad copy that the collector
had and the book was disguised with a
red line all around it so even early on
as the 18th century you you had the
fetishization of the Shakespeare text so
that even a bad one was something that
people were struggling and paying
immense amounts of money so I just want
to this this is an example of the first
corner of Hamlet we photographed all
seven of the individual copies only
seven exist and you can click on those
then we have an art collection of
fifteen hundred images from 1700 to 1900
this is the cupping photograph of Hamlet
in the skull we illustrate in the line
the last poor Yorick I knew him Horatio
but there are others and we found that
maybe thirty percent of the illustration
in that period was comical well so
here's a guy holding a rather gigantic
Neanderthal skull this is 19th century
and then in the corner there's a little
chicken rooster meditating on death's
and yes he's got a skull you know if
more recently deceased comrade and he
stands in much greater danger of
death than the actor Harrison wolf with
his giant head kind of imitating
Shakespeare's had so many many comic
versions is one of the things you find
when you study variation in in the text
and in their performance we also wanted
to have video we had a little trouble
getting copyright ie we got a
permissions but we did get permissions
from mrs. Burton for the to display the
Richard Burton Hamlet it's a very fine
one and we wanted to at least exemplify
the concept and then we another one we
got was the Swedish television version
directed by Greg nihilist and with stem
cells guard as as Hamlet and just play
this for a second become the only words
in Swedish that I know so ok now having
having done that you know we we came to
a point in our work where we have the
opportunity to expand and we decided not
to expand that model at least not now I
mean the original model and there were
there are certain reasons about how
expensive it is to handling thousands
and thousands of lines to one another
which may be more possible and easier to
automate today but we what we realized
was we wanted something that was a
little less there's two things right a
little less text driven and more
performance driven and also something
that would deal with Shakespeare as
interpreted elsewhere in the world and
we have a very fortunate conjunction of
the possibility of a grant to do
this with the development of a
collection already taking place in in
our collaborator Alex Wang's collection
that he was developing at Penn State for
which he'd already begun to get online
permissions before he had a way of
putting them up so we're now partners in
this enterprise and and this is a video
centric archive right so it does not
actually contain a text of Shakespeare
but it contains at present 25 to 30 full
full video records of of productions
from a number of countries notably Japan
Taiwan People's Republic and with Korea
coming so East Asia and so that so
that's what we decided was a good move
to take two steps away from the
domination of the text and this also
this also converged with the
understanding the changing understanding
of Shakespeare in Asia I mean one way of
looking at it like in in Japan in in
1905 in 1910 they would send people to
Russia to study how Stanislavski put on
the Cherry Orchard or put on another
kind of a play and imitate the exact
gestures by 1996 these Asian countries
have become centers of innovation and
Shakespeare in my own view is that
unrivaled centers of innovation know far
more interesting things happening in
Japan or in Taiwan and China than in
Great Britain as far as opening up the
tests to new understandings so that's
what we wanted to do they said this is
one of our interfaces for that but
another one is this and it's a matrix
you know and so I'm our second version
we're going to start with some version
of a video matrix and you click on one
and you brought into the video
performance itself a second stage the
randomized the filling of the matrix we
randomized will be different and
mais third-stage it won't be randomized
but it will conform as these
sophisticated online things now due to
your own choices to your own interest to
the pathways that you may be that you
may be following and the third thing
which I can exemplify because we're
working on it now is that we wanted to
we wanted to find a place for sort of
scholarly Shakespeare and serious
archives within a media ecology that
includes examples of interactive or
community uses of video that far
transcend what we could do in quantity
and also frankly in design of a space in
which ordinary people can put up their
material enjoy it communicate it around
it and of course I'm thinking of the
video sites and YouTube in particular so
one of our the goals of the new project
is to be open not only to try to be open
to other cultures to a variation to in
performance but also to the decentered
world of contribution and communication
of of the contemporary social aspects of
the web and and at least the first start
will be to have YouTube connection
within the archive where people can post
there are YouTube playlists and where we
also engage a wider public in sifting
material that would be useful for for
online essays or enlarging the material
we have so these is just a taste of ways
in which we've tried to go beyond that
parentheses but at the same time I think
with the realization that I don't know
if we can say that we've an now entered
a freer world in every way you know
there's going to be more restrictions
and more ways in which what is that one
of one of that I think the Folger
education departments books is called
freeing Shakespeare's words and that's
that's a title very much in consonance
with Tom's
so I wanted to give an example of ways
in which one could try to go beyond this
thank you thank you thank you Pete
excellent combination of presentations
here because the one has the abstract
theory and the other has the concrete
examples and I think it's very exciting
work so what I'd like to do now is open
the session to discussion william
actually we would like people to speak
into the microphone so I could okay
the excellent yeah so indeed thank you
both
also for raising the methodological
fundamental methodological issue here of
how high to fly take the 300 foot router
than 50 thousand heels very different
data I mean Pete you did a great job of
showing the incredible variability of a
so-called stable era and Tom pattern
recognition is a tricky thing and I
think I want to address my question to
you the paranthesis
I can take a lot of the same symptoms
you've offered and read them I'm sure
anyone can sort of come up with but you
know just to say that if we think about
before the 15th century we could talk
about an era of embodiment the others
containment that its containment through
the body the body writes the word the
church the body of the church is the
storage facility for it cartography is
very much about embodied sites we could
think about the period after the 15th
century in terms of we could capture
that in a word like the algorithmic
right the ability to fix to get precise
mathematical meaning three-point
perspective is an invention of this as
much as the book and you pointed to the
frame my difficulty with your analysis
comes at the other side of the
parenthesis where we are today because I
would say well if we think about Google
Google is a great example we might think
about a shift from the algorithmic the
notion of a precise calculable fixable
stable mathematical order to something
like the algorithmic which is precession
which works in the world of the computer
an old term Euclid uses it but it never
really gets deployed very effectively
until the coming of the computer the
ability to process the algorithmic is
not about certainty or fixity it's about
a formula it's about the precession the
the procedural in a certain way and
Google is a great example of that
because they change the algorithm I
don't know twice a day or twice a week
or something to keep everyone guessing
about what's really going to come up you
can't game it you can't predict it
Photosynth would be a great counterpart
to three-point perspective Photosynth
with its melding and morphing of
hundreds of photographs into one sort of
seething space there is no point of view
heidecker's notion of the the world
picture is is is shattered is destroyed
there there is no subject object
relationship that's discernible that was
the project of the 15th century onwards
but we don't have that anymore and it's
not in the same way that it was embodied
before the 15th we could talk about it
with something like the project of the
encyclopedia which which works very well
in the in the era of print but Wikipedia
is something where your contributions
are there but constantly being
repositioned by an algorithm so I would
argue that by argue by talking about a
parentheses what you what's occluded
there is the computational the error
that were in that allows a very
different order of and in fact the
algorithmic which is something that
starts to intervene between us between
the subject and the object there's a
principle there's a process there's a
formula there that often we don't see
but that actually is doing the mediation
between us and the phenomenon that we
that we encounter at the end thanks very
much I'll take that on board a lot of
the terms you use seemed quite
encouraging interactive D centric
procession and things being being mixed
up together I've used art a bit thinking
about art and pictures and so on I've a
point I've noticed is that there's a
change in the there is a change in the
way the body is represented in
in connection with this the opening of
the of the parentheses
for example the body of Christ in the
crucifixion that does yeah you're
talking about embodiment in abstract
terms I'm thinking very much of it the
actual body in the picture and which is
where I feel more at home the actual
representation of bodies shifts in the
late Middle Ages and going into the
sixteenth century for example the body
the body of Christ was originally very
angular the body was almost coordinate
with the cross with the the limbs
following exactly the shape of the cross
of the body is articulate the body is a
conjunction of limbs and joints and then
as we move as well there's a
correspondence as we move into the
period where as it happens books are
being printed and becoming more
important then the body of Christ takes
on a more enveloping shape that we get a
greater in the body sags away from the
cross a greater emphasis on the ribcage
as a as a hollow a hollowing out
envelope the the belly sags and there's
a notion of of the body being penetrable
and of essences coming out of the body
there's a shift there and that that
business of that those portraits of
Renaissance women with those distended
bellies it was kind of difficult a
fashion for presenting women with them
with very sort of Pro true brand
stomachs at this time and it doesn't
seem it wasn't because they were
pregnant it wasn't because they were
standing in a particular way I don't
think but because it's just that's just
how the female body became to be seen
for a while
I can I can respond I can respond to you
in terms of actual bodies rather than
processes of embodiment and I shall need
to explore further the points that you
were making about arithmetic and
algorithms and the like but thank you
thank you Alex
hi thanks very much for talking Kandra
in CMS it's very interesting I have to
say the Gutenberg parenthesis is a
concept that's been stuck with me for
the last few weeks I've been thinking
about it and I like the idea that
there's something about oral culture
that can tell us something new about
today I mean I was thinking you know
it's certainly true if we think of how
gossip works it doesn't that seem
similar to some of the things that
happen online the kind of communication
and the way that it's sort of
information plus a social relationship
right you choose to join this or that
stream of things coming through but you
know I there's also sort of ephemerality
I think the oral culture that were sort
of returning to with digital culture as
we lose all of our photos all of a
sudden and a reminded of the the way
storage is tricky but one of the things
I guess my question though is it's
related to Williams in the sense that
you know that how do we see what comes
after the parentheses right and that if
orality if the medieval present is an
image beforehand and then print and then
the Internet is the process we're trying
to talk about it seems to me that with
the medieval present the peasant trying
to say something right he's sort of
limited to who can hear from the soapbox
right in the middle of the town square
and that one of the things print and
abled was getting that the opinion that
voice across much greater distance right
there's a different kind of permanence
and a different kind of mobility that
comes with print and it seems to me that
one way to read then this next step is a
quantum leap in exactly that same print
kind of thing that there's even greater
mobility and instead of being
constrained by the package it's easy to
copy and and multiply so sort of
mobility and multiplicity is sort of
what comes with the internet and so in
that sense it seems to me
I'm not sure right or if it's a pretty
it's in more open parentheses or a
bracket at the other end I'm not sure
that it's the previous then goes with
the forward and so I guess my question
is you know in what sense if you could
give us more of a sense of how this
understanding morality and the medieval
peasant can give us a greater sense of
what's happening in media today maybe
there's some other examples I mean I'm
just categories and boundaries going
down but where can we see that I guess
what I'm looking to hear right there's a
phrase I should have introduced into my
presentation perhaps wasn't there the
post parenthetical period is a reversion
to the pre parenthetical at a higher
level of technology we've got it we've
got to take that into account there are
there are going to be aspects of this
which are print which will be which will
take print to a higher level they'll be
taking taking the some of the advantages
of print to a higher level but in so
doing they will undermine other aspects
of print like the permanence of print
like the like the stability of of the
message which will take us back to the
the pre the preprint period it isn't yes
it isn't just a question of as I said
before of a preprint orality coming back
in the form of a prose post print
orality it is in the form of text but
texts are changing texts are texts
getting out of control
Tec texts are becoming free and they are
escaping from the confines of the book
it may well be that there will be more
texts any one text will be multiplied
more any any one and I mean text rather
than speech that any one text will be
multiplied as a text and be more mobile
as a text than texts were previously but
in becoming mobile and in and in being
multiplied it will become less stable it
will be free for the person who mediates
it can change it add to it subtract from
it make it make it their own texts are
becoming mobile texts are becoming
it as a as a part of that process and
the other part of it well think thinking
of the thinking of the medieval peasant
the medieval peasant was also mobile of
course he could go he could go from one
village to another the the the perform
the spreader of a rumor let's not say a
peasant and let's say a Carta could take
his rumor from one village to another
and spread it on to another group of
people it was to say it was it was mo
but mobile in that sense and probably
the rumor probably changed each time
each time he told it just as things will
change every time they get repeated on
the internet from from from from one
site to another I like I'm grateful for
the reference to two categories though
because I've been thinking about the
implications of all this forum well for
the spread of the news and the squared
of rumor and so on and I think that is
one way the medieval peasant probably
had different sources of information
different kinds of version different
rumors came to him in different ways but
I'd not certain he had a hierarchy of
trust in those different sources in the
meantime we have had a hierarchy we've
had a period well I don't know I think
we've said well it must be true I read
it in a newspaper the print has convert
conferred or authority on certain kinds
of news but now we're going back to the
medieval situation where we can't really
tell newspapers are becoming more like
rumor in the sense that they are they
are being made available in the same
kind of sources the same kind of media
as a rumors it's it is harder I mean it
is now harder for us to tell what we
read in newspapers the rumor and when we
hear a rumor is it is it with the same
Authority as newspapers there's a the
category to the category of unofficial
medium of informal medium and the
category of official medium is breaking
down and we would say we are we are
losing that hierarchy our categories of
news are breaking down and I see that as
a very much reversion to we can't sort
them out we're going through a confusing
period yeah can I seem talk about
Shakespeare all right
sorry hi I'm Nick Seaver I'm a grad
student in comparative Media Studies and
I have a question about well about one
of the images that you showed actually
which was the enraged musician because I
think it has interesting ramifications
yeah be crazy it's on the handout is it
is it on the handout it is on there also
I don't know forget it okay well so the
question is sort of about about history
and about period making because so
there's a lot of you know things that
start happening at roughly the same time
because you mentioned it and of course
what's implied in here is that these
things also happen in particular places
and not in other places the parenthesis
is around you know the musician inside
not around the people outside and so in
a certain sense I think was implicit
somewhat you said that the future comes
at different times to different to
different people and I and I of course
about how useful it is maybe to think
about this can this period of
containment in such a contained way as
if everyone at one time is doing the
same thing there's a sense of which I
know we're talking william brought up
this big picture a little picture
question this is certainly related but
it seems like bracketing off this
historical period does blurs over some
other kinds of bracketing that might
happen for example in this image of
class but of race and gender and all of
these are sort of containments that we
might do it was curious that your
response i'm very thank you very much
for asking that question and for drawing
our attention to this picture because i
went very lightly and very confusedly
over it in my strangely wired condition
and there's more to get there's more to
be said about this and this also helps
me to emphasize you've reminded me to
emphasize a point which could have been
a game could be made more more clearly
it's a question of the incidence of the
timing different cultures enter the
parenthesis at different times and will
exit presumably at different times
within any one culture different
subcultures will enter the parenthesis
at different times so at any one moment
there'll be people inside and people
outside
and Hogarth's enraged musician i've
always found that a very good way of
thinking making me think about what's
going on because this is i mean it's
it's a Hogarth's way of saying that some
forms of art are becoming parenthetical
his the musician in the window is the
italian leader of the coffin garden
orchestra and the point the point
Hogarth and not not in my terms of
course but the point Hogarth is making
is that there is a growing wall between
the Fine Arts and the street and this
isn't healthy a nice I see I see that as
one of the those parallel developments
to the opening of the parentheses so
that it that it's quite that it's quite
great the that musician is well in the
parentheses correctors make the point in
case you check I've reversed the picture
because Hogarth didn't realize that
there was a parenthesis so he put the he
put the street on the right I deter Ida
took me hours I had to turn it around to
get it the right way the point the but
you see the point is that it's about
music and words so within the
parenthesis we have the we have the
opera musician who you can just see is
playing his music from a printed score
and who will be producing performing in
opera in a confined Opera House to which
only the elite have have access and only
the people who have the right taste and
the right money have access and even the
blind ballad singer in the street
outside she is singing songs but she's
also selling songs which are printed and
she's selling them as as commodities is
that these are broadside ballads so we
have to feel like we have an elite
culture and a form of commercial popular
culture I do wish Hogarth had put the
blind ballad singer sort of a bit filete
so he's not quite as far into the
parentheses as the as the as the thing
but this this is precisely the point
while some parts of culture are getting
themselves confined and cut off and
becoming culture with a capital C and
becoming physically confined in
two dedicated venues like opera houses
between them there is a fence and a wall
between them and the world of what
Hogarth is saying natural music real
music folk music the music with energy
the music of the street and he's saying
that that will be to the detriment that
we will get a refined a tattoo refined
or too refined artistic music which is
losing contact with its roots in the
street so that so in one of the same
period in London there are there are
parenthetical people and there are pre
parenthetical people and there's only
the window between them they are losing
they're losing touch with each other
Marty this is Marty Marx from the music
section thank you both very much and all
of you I mean I think this is really
brilliant this discussion but I have to
ask why parenthesis why not
dashes or ellipses and in pretty the
reason I'm saying that is because at
certain points every time you spoke
about another you win in another
direction I kept thinking how fertile
that was for example that the fragment
versus the closed work and as I've
always thought about the history of
European intellectuals and so forth I've
always thought that romanticism was
already the rebellion against
confinement there was ultimately defined
by the Enlightenment that in a sense the
culmination of your move your
representation of confinement is the
Enlightenment encyclopedia as the Summum
bonum of of the collection of knowledge
but and the romantics revel in fragments
the romantics in music in poetry
I mean I'm my areas music but I know
that in other areas to look at look at
the great voids ik by Buechner for
example of 1820s which is nothing but
fragments and how how that was in a
sense part of the the revolution against
rationality so the only reason I bring
that up is and I'm hoping Pete could
have kentuc and then you just mentioned
the broadside ballad and I was thinking
well why doesn't Pete talk about
newspapers in ballad and broad sides
because they were just as much a part of
the culture of print in the
shakespeare's day as were books or
cortos if not more and then of course
I'm thinking about Aristotle who's the
beginning and isn't isn't the
Renaissance ha's impetus towards
confinement and categorization based on
their rediscovery of Aristotelian texts
but when we look at it that way when we
look at it in terms of the perm the
infinite malleability of the human
intellect to go in different directions
at the same time towards confinement and
escape towards the divine and the real
the concrete towards the natural and the
supernatural when we look at it that way
what does it really have to do with
media except perhaps on the grandest
scale of hong's idea of orality and
print or in reality and written culture
he doesn't really talk about print
culture he talks about a reality in
written culture which is not quite the
same thing so if we but if we extend it
in one direction towards Aristotle this
debate this this opening up of the
parenthesis and we defend extended in
another direction by breaking down the
parenthesis in the 19th century rather
than the 20th how do we rate relate that
to the media scheme that we're talking
about new media old media pre old media
old old old media and so forth I don't I
don't see how it all fits together and I
think the word parenthesis is itself
such a confining concept that you are in
fact recapitulating the argument that
you're trying to undermine or something
I'm this is all my thoughts at this
point I don't know how you're gonna deal
with that as a question
he asked you to say something first oh
hey I would say something I don't know
much about valleys and broad sides but I
can refer people with complete
confidence to the work of Tiffany Stern
at Oxford on an ephemeral paper in
Shakespeare's time and it's astounding I
mean so there the world of London that
she describes is one in which every
conceivable surface is it has a bill
what if he says post no bills they
posted bills you know every place and
these could be bills for advertising a
performance of a play they could be just
dozens of things advertisements but they
were they were everywhere and she's
documented this so we have I mean as
that contrasted in my mind the wonderful
olivier film and henry v there's a
single play bill that falls from the sky
and then becomes the screen and the
credits for opening credits you know but
but but it's notable that's just a
single one and the picture that she's
describing is that a kind of free paper
unbound paper unlicensed paper right
unregulated paper fraudulent paper paper
that contained rumors was was everywhere
in in london in 1600 the that's one
dated little data micro point another
would be a little bit later they are as
we were talking about rumor the
gabrielle no days book on the discovery
of the egregious and postures of the
Rosicrucian Brotherhood in 1625 even no
day and was the librarian of Richelieu
an important figure in in that history
and one of the one of the chapters of
the book and the rise of equations is
about how rumors you say there are three
dangerous the common trope there were
three dangerous inventions in our time
by which he means back to 1450 or sell
gunpowder and the printing press and I
forgot the other one but it must have
been pretty dangerous but something
obvious but anyway
by the printing press and the printing
press because any any crazy person with
an idea about overthrowing the state
could get a bunch of leaflets printed
rumors about miraculous events could
could could thrive in a way that go
beyond carting them individually from
one place to another
so there's sort of an idea that the
printing press unloosed
unlicensed irrational elicit paper is is
a part of the Shakespearean picture I
mean they're just amazing scenarios that
she has a descriptions of the lady of a
house that was rich enough to have
servants would send out a servant in the
morning to rip all the paper off that
she might be interested off of the walls
that off of the posts and bring it home
in a pile at the lady of the house would
then peruse it that was the newspaper
right and of course then there had to be
pasted back up by somebody else that
they had to keep doing the rounds to
keep the city properly pasted over but
we don't have that idea of London when
we go or when we go to a tourist village
like Stratford or Oxford or Cambridge
you know when we have old buildings we
think of them as uh nun unencumbered but
a nun by graffiti or by pasted up paper
but they were so there's just a couple
of things but broadsides would be a very
important part of this just make one one
observation here the the idea of a
parenthesis is very provocative I find
interesting for making us think before
and after but the idea that we are
moving to a post literate society is
very hard for me to understand because
the entire technological framework that
makes this media this immersion media
culture possible is super literate it's
it's depends on vast amounts of
commentary more publications and we and
the humanities can even imagine these
regimes are used constantly and I would
also note that the the people who
inhabit the realms of the social media
so in all the different areas of popular
culture are themselves super literate
they are constantly writing they are
constantly communicating with each other
through texts the level of understanding
of the word is probably beyond anything
has ever been so the notion of the
parentheses that we are actually
returning to a preliterate society I
think needs to be modified somewhat by
saying well it's it's not either or is
both an what we are actually merging
into is something that is both a new
secondary orality that is massively
supported by a super literacy and so we
have to deal with that because that's
not easy to deal with because but I
think this this idea of parentheses
maybe giving us the wrong kind of
emphasis that you know we're returning
to something that was before I don't
think that past is ever going to be
recovered but elements of it and
experiences of it of course can but
supported by something that is
fundamentally it's a little like
sometimes I think of wealth in the Eloi
in the Morlocks you know the Morlocks
are down there you know grinding out and
creating this possible culture then the
yellow hair on the top but that's not
really what's happening it's it's
something that's more complicated so I
don't know if you want to comment on
I'll just take a response to that and
perhaps say a word or two in defense of
the parentheses as an image but your
aren't the answer was in what you said
in the sense that the users of the new
media are super literate and they are
all writing that's the difference
in the parenthesis there are writers and
readers there are a few writers and many
readers and the new age is one in which
you can't really tell the difference
between a reader and a writer because
they are all they're all writing they
are all writing and communicating with
the same freedom that before the
parenthesis they were all speaking we
are reproducing with texts the kind of
fluidity the interaction and the
declining categories that the breakdown
in categories between the creator and
the receiver and the consumer that was
there with speech we'd say always
getting close to it I think on in his
notes for this a new edition of his work
that never came out was started to think
about a secondary literacy a new kind of
literacy which was
so widespread and so easily acceptable
that people his people were writing to
each other with the same freedom on the
same ease and in the same syntax as they
spoke to each other previously before
before the princes and with regard to
the princes itself it's certainly I mean
it's provocative it's more it's good
it's provocative if like that's one of
its good points because it's it's better
than dashes or series of dots because it
insists on a return - there can be there
can be several sort of dashes in a
sequence the prenta parenthesis is such
a provocative way of saying there was
this pause one idea was going forward we
stopped we left that for a moment went
into another idea and then we came back
to the first idea like it's not going
backwards it's not perhaps I'm wrong to
say we're gonna be like medieval
peasants but we are resuming where we
left off
we were moving forward at a certain
point then we stopped and did something
else and now we're reverting to where we
were and moving on beyond that and it's
appropriate if I just managed to say I
think in that the parenthesis itself is
a renascence invention and invention
within within within the world within
the world of print and with regard to
Aristotle and the rediscovery of
classical notions I made this point when
I was here the first time talking about
this and I still think it's right
although it gets rid of Gutenberg
cultures can move in and out of this
kind of parenthesis through the years a
given culture can start to drift in
towards the parenthesis which i think is
what happened in the Classical period in
the greco-roman Classical period there
was a kind of a it's like ice ages there
was a mini ice age a mini textual age in
the Classical period where where writing
was becoming more dominant but without
the advantage of print and then we moved
out of it again in the in the Middle
Ages and the renascence we discovered it
can I make one last point about
fragments romance fragments it is quite
right that romance writing was a kind of
bid for freedom in writing fragments and
not being confined by the rules and by
the conventions but I bet they did it on
purpose
I bet it was self-conscious it wasn't
their default mode fragments and
incompleteness are the default mode
before the princess or maybe it again
after the parenthesis a deliberate
revolt against convention and
confinement in itself is a neck is
rather like the back Tinian uncontained
body you can't you can't you can't have
your back Tilian carnivalesque rebellion
against the contained body unless you're
the norm is the contained body so I
would thought the wrote romantic
romantic fragments romantic
fragmentation is self conscious
fragmentation which in a way
acknowledges that the norm is
containment is completeness closure
my name is les Roman I'm writing a
humanistic studies and several lifetimes
ago I was a medieval lust and I just
actually wanted as I was standing up
here I was actually going to make the
same kind of point that Jim made and I'd
like to sort of give some conch
examples that the parentheses doesn't
seem to be the right thing because it
seems to be same but different in in
very very different ways for example
hierarchy the Middle Ages was very big
on hierarchy the internet if anything is
very flat
I think the difference between
production and consumption that oral
tradition you needed to have production
everywhere or else you would not have
you know you if you wanted to play in
your town if you wanted to have a
mystery play you put it on you know the
various guilds put it on if I want to
see something now I can just go to
YouTube
the fact is that many more people can
produce but you don't necessarily have
to produce you can just consume much
more than you could always consume
before with many more choices and you
know I know that one last point I'd like
to make is with the whole idea of
containment and hypertext in the Middle
Ages not so much in the oral tradition
but in the book tradition was the whole
idea of the Hypertech the incipient
notion of the hypertext in the Ovid
moralization in the Talmud and those
things only become really viable now in
the digital age yes yes I would
I would see that as compatible with the
parenthesis if we acknowledge that the
parenthesis is multiple comprising
several calibrated or a broad fuzzy
parenthesis and and that some forms of
textual communication I like the notion
of the the text which is commented the
text which carries its own comment and
that we are I'm I'm happy about that in
the sense that that the way in modern
times we can we can freely comment on an
adjustor text is taking us back not
merely to the era of speech but to a
manuscript era
in the sense that with a manuscript it's
when you're speaking it's hard to
distinguish between the like the
authoritative voice and the voice that
interrupts and with writing you can as
with sort of authority of manuscripts
you can have the scribal text and then
you could have the annotations and the
marginal comments and they can look as
authoritative and scripts copied they
can look as authoritative they differ in
degree rather than in kind from the the
main text and then with the printed book
you can jolly well see that you
distinguish between the the text itself
which is printed and then the
annotations are clearly in hand and they
belong to a different a different
category of communication so it's
certainly that part I think I can I'm
comfortable with thanks very much
Mary fuller from the literature section
so one of the things that I kept
thinking really if almost from the
beginning of your talk was that I didn't
recognize in early modern books the kind
of book that you were talking about sort
of the autonomous the enclosed the
bordered and so on and so forth what I
did recognize was an idea of the book
that as Pete was saying dates back was
certainly you know one finds it in the
80s and earlier decades but it strikes
me that in some sense it's a very modern
idea of the book and a very modern
practice of the book and practice of
reading the book I don't recognize it in
the early modern texts that I work with
which are compilations of put together
by the editor sort of effectively
hyperlinked to all kinds of contexts
outside the body by the editor okay
compilations made by the editor very
popular kind of book annotated by the
editor annotated by readers used in
practice etc etc etc sort of
agglomerations of things that only don't
look like networks if we don't
understand the kind of books they are
but that's an effect of our readership
of them of our loss of the local context
and so you know and and then it you know
as I was sitting I had a lot of time to
think about this as I was sitting on the
steps
this is making me really sort of
distrust a larger narrative of the
parenthesis is an interruption which at
the same time you have moved away from
sort of repeatedly and said well
actually it's much more mobile and local
and people come in and out of it and
someone and so forth it strikes me that
you know my ability to work with these
early modern books in the way that I
have the last few years is effectively
being networks sort of full of
hyperlinks and so on and so forth is
very much a function of the moment the
historical moment which I'm doing that
work because I think that perspective
wasn't wouldn't have been available 30
years ago right and so it seems to me
that the digital era has reactivated
certain kinds of lost potential in the
Gutenberg Age that were never not there
but were not seen by us for a period
just as it seems to be reactivating
certain kinds of lost potential in the
manuscript and oral age so I can't make
that into a question but I'll just leave
it to you to respond as you wish you say
early modern books does it is it a
transitional phenomena or does it carry
on into the 18th 19th centuries you were
saying it's more I I think that's fair
enough that the Gutenberg parenthesis is
is cumulative and so the increases in
depth or increases in intensity as time
goes by so that it'll take some time to
get to the time of the kind of book I'm
imagining and I like the I I like I I
like they do it's rather correspond
rather to what what Peter was saying
that the digital age is helping us to
find things that were there that we
couldn't really see before or handle
before in in in earlier periods but is
it do you get these compilations in the
19th century they just carry on I don't
work in the 19th century so I couldn't
really say I wouldn't want to say that
they don't occur then all right but
there's I mean it's it's it's good it's
going to be varied it's going to be
modeled it's going to it's going to it's
going to be transitional but now I mean
that well thank but thank you for I've
been waiting to thump this book into the
table for quite some time now what I
mean by that the kind of contained book
is this one this is what's effect simile
this is what they did to shakespeare
shakespeare's plays which were designed
for performance and
bears plays which weren't terribly
original all the time Shakespeare's
plays which were in some cases rewrites
of existing plays and which deployed
traditional materials in traditional
ways and Shakespeare's plays which were
themselves subjected to enormous
intervention by the actors and which
were taken around from place to place
and perform by the actors not always
very accurately those living plays that
living pre parenthetical uncontained
culture of highways and junctions
textual highways and junctions and real
highways and junctions it was imprisoned
well thank heavens because otherwise you
wouldn't have the place but we can just
say thank you thank thank you but
goodbye to the the printers this is it I
mean say this this is a facsimile but
this will this will be something like it
all of its it's a book it's considered
to be the complete works complete place
of an author and all the plays are
complete all the plays are claimed to be
in better more authentic versions than
had been available individually
previously and here it is it all these
they all that the text the text is with
its margins with a very a very careful
line around the text to make sure the
words don't start sort of crawling out
of the page and then they printed in
that press the pages are folded into
gatherings and Stitch the gatherings are
stitched together and the the volume is
then glued and given covers and the
cover that covers are stitched together
or glued together and the book is put
into its case and Shakespeare and his
living world is carefully encapsulated
and then what do you get then thank you
for this this chance of fate is
ionization
the fetishistic approach well once
you've turned Shakespeare into a thing
you can start to relate to it
in a not in an other than textual manner
and I've had great pleasure over the
years in and I've brought you a small
sample from my collection of slightly
unhealthy at advertisements for for
Shakespeare's plays if you go
the Oxford Complete Works I have an
adverse meant for the leather-bound
edition of the Oxford Shakespeare
Complete Works an exquisite edition
bound bound in dark green leather gilt
edged pages and with the sort of special
birth special Shakespeare stamp I have
the another version of the Oxford
Shakespeare the complete works
Shakespeare's complete works in
exquisite blue calfskin and then this is
the ardent the ardent complete works
bound in genuine maroon leather with
gold embossed title lettering marbled
end papers and a ribbon marker
exquisitely presented volume that will
appeal to book liquors and Shakespeare
lovers throughout the world not they're
not supposed to read it that you're
supposed to look at it stroke it Mary
Harper years ago been around CMS and
whatnot I first off say I'm a little
biased I tend to be dubious about the
use of the parentheses this bit
artificial since there's I think there's
more continuity and the forces that came
before and during are continuous and
always there and in parallel all the
time a different person signatures and
proportions but they're continuous now
and passed and it will be in the future
also I think media history tends to be
that one form of media doesn't replace
another as much as it tends to be
continuous and additives so the books
will continue in the forces of the books
people will make their eBook readers
hold just a single book and contain it
very carefully and storage will continue
to improve to the point where it will be
long term and permanent so it's not that
it's just gonna go away but you did
mention that in the preview do use the
parenthesis and you get to the point
where you say okay well what comes after
it's different you have said you do know
that what comes after will be forever
impacted by what is inside the
parenthesis so even if you use it up I'm
just curious how would you represent
what comes after as being impacted by
what came within have you thought about
what you would do to make it quite clear
that what is after has been forever
changed by what is inside the
parenthesis say or in the imagery so
probably in the imagery but even if it's
just the language yes but I think I
think so the print the parenthesis in
itself suggests that in the it invites a
syntactical analogy in that the
sentences are changed but the other in
turn in simply in terms of words as I
have said previously that we it's a cut
it's a reversion to where we were
carrying on from where we left off but
at a higher level of technology and I'm
trying to haven't succeeded yet in a
platter need a three-dimensional diagram
to try and indicate that the matter of
time because it does just having the one
parenthesis on the page looks like we
all do it at the same time and it's it's
complete and total that's the worst
thing about the parenthesis one of my
diagrams had to I noticed just just as a
symbolic indication that there are
multiple parenthesis so one side in a
colon on the other or something like
open you get out one side I've been
using three kinds of brackets since our
Maya so on my material that I've used a
round bracket and a square bracket and
one of those squiggly ones that it needs
I need if you're if you're visual I need
some way to multiply the lines to
multiply the simpler lines representing
change and I also need I also need some
means to indicate the time factor but
not all not all things happen at the
same time with regard to the conjugate
so I've been thinking about continuity
you're quite right and I'm very much
that that every time something new is
introduced what's there most of it
carries on I've been thinking a lot
about that and and will for example
print itself comes on in on top of and
in addition to the written book and in
many ways the printed book doesn't
qualitatively doesn't do a lot more
there's not much difference between a
printed book and a written one in that
sense in the columns but it struck me
that but surely it is must be relevant
that there were just so many more of
them
so what whatever do whatever it is a
book does print multiplies
quantitatively so it'll it'll it'll have
a greater impact it was some some of it
was there already
it becomes endemic it becomes it becomes
much bigger so it can it can contribute
in that way being short I'm gonna leave
the last comment Pete and thank you all
for a very stimulating conversation and
idea that Shakespeare would have shared
the devaluation of the book because the
evidence is of the contrary as wonderful
a dramatist as Shakespeare was there's a
strong anti see a trickle element to his
art when the stage doesn't always isn't
always portrayed as a place of truth and
you know it's perfect often portrayed
negatively and if for instance in the
sonnet where he speaks of my nature is
subdued almost to what it works in like
the dyers hand so you know the the the
profession of being a playwright is
subdue his nature and then he goes on to
say public manners public sins beget or
something like that figured exactly what
it is but the idea is that his
profession of writing for that public
stage is degrading and and so you know
this is this is part of the portrait of
Shakespeare not that it was all that he
thought obviously not you know it's not
to say that's the whole story but it's
part of this story and another is that
there's a lot of evidence that
Shakespeare was confined by the stage
rather than by the book and some of this
is in look at Lucas urns arguments and
Shakespeare the dramatic artists
dramatic literary artist if you get the
exact time Lucas Aaron and Geneva and
this is just one example of it but I
think very telling one so a play like
Henry the fifth which has been read as a
pacifist play as a radical play as a
radical reproach to Authority to war to
the state and so on in the 20th century
and as as often as an authoritarian play
and any hero play but the the grounding
of the reading of Henry the fifth as
radical in some measure comes entirely
from almost entirely from parts of the
play that were that are in the folio and
not in the court oh because the public
stage was more more assiduous Lee
censored so for example I mean I think
of one example but it's with many ways
in which the war against France is
relativize and called into question is
done by the work of the chorus who pops
up between each act and who is entirely
absent in the court oh that was
published during Shakespeare's life and
it was likely to be closer to
performance than the folio version or
the passage in the fourth chorus where
he's comparing Henry King Henry
returning in triumph to London and to
the arrival of other noble general Essex
from Ireland bringing rebellion broach
it on his sword a line that hovers
between having defeated maybe he'll
defeat the Irish rebels but also maybe
as actually happened in real life and
for which he was executed he brought
rebellion home to London and challenged
the Queen and an unsuccessful
revolt against the state so and that's
the only topical reference to current
events
that's undoubted in the shakespeare kind
all of that's in the folio none of it is
and is in the cuarto so you do have some
freedoms in print that are striking
sometimes relative to being hauled in
for what might be performed on the
public stage so it can really work both
ways also performance can be confining
the way actors did their parts in
Shakespeare's time could be very
confining because they didn't have the
full play they didn't do a read-through
they didn't read the book they had cues
their parts and the cue in part and cue
in part so the freedom of the performer
was we would have thought a severely
limited you know to an textually
directed it wasn't it wasn't free and as
Tom of course knows there was criticism
in Shakespeare's plays of the of the
freedom of this stage of the clown
saying more and in Hamlet and so on of
that period outside the parentheses or
later you'll you'll get the notion that
after the restoration that there's an
authority and performance just as
there's a confining authority in print
the confining authority in print comes
from what's on the page the confining
authority from performance consists in
the need to establish that a better ten
for example the the leading actor of the
time had learned his part in Hamlet from
so-and-so who'd learned it from Francis
Taylor who'd learned it from the author
you know and there's and there's a great
deal of attention to creating these
genealogies of performance authority
that go back just as the fetishize book
does to the notion of the controlling
author so I don't think there's a
panacea in performance or you know that
was that one of these forms is
necessarily only confining in another
liberating it's a complicated story in a
Shakespeare's case I think that the case
is pretty good that he was both a
literary artist as well as a theatrical
professional and lest we forget every
age invents its own forms of confinement
we now have copy
right and the Internet is a perfect in
strelsau we still work with these things
but thank you very much for a very
stimulating conversation